une technique et des gestes ancestraux
artistes peintre Elisa le Veillard a
troqué la toile contre une plaque de
cuivre pour parfaire sa maîtrise de la
gravure ce qui m'intéresse le plus
là-dedans c'est le côté primitif j'aime
bien quand je me salue les morts par
exemple avec la peinture
originaire de Paris la jeune artiste
prend encore ses marques à l'atelier
jacrobach où elle doit passer une
semaine en résidence j'avais préparé ma
plaque j'avais mis le vernis et ensuite
ça s'appelle une pointe sèche donc avec
la pointe je vais directement venir
graver sur le vernis donc je vais faire
mon dessin
ensuite
je vais aller les faire tremper dans un
bain d'acide et donc c'est grâce à
l'acide que les plaques vont être
creusées
pour l'accompagner dans ses premières
réalisations elle peut compter sur
Mathias Lenny artiste lui aussi il s'est
formé ici même à la gravure et ses
différents procédés sur le lino on
creuse les blancs
c'est à dire tout ce qui est creusé va
disparaître
et on pense à l'envers bien sûr on pense
écrire à l'envers et les formes à
l'envers
sur le cuivre ce que l'on creuse va
faire apparaître les Noirs c'est à dire
l'encre va rentrer dans les creux donc
c'est que le principe du négatif et du
positif là on pense en négatif sur le
cuivre on pense comme une image dessinée
traditionnelle voilà donc là maintenant
qu'il est ancré je vais pouvoir le
passer sous la presse et l'imprimer et
vous l'offrir
une fois imprimé sur du papier la
gravure devient une estampe cette
technique j'accrobaque en était un
maître respecté pendant 30 ans il a
gravé puis imprimer des images dans son
atelier
font entrer dans la matière c'est pas
simplement
des mettre annules de métal non non
c'est toucher aussi celui-ci
avec le temps le maître a eu tendance à
conserver sa production pour lui à
l'exposition et la publicité il
préférait la transmission j'ai toujours
désiré être indépendant et être libre
donc pour moi être artiste c'est ça
avant tout c'est être libre après la
mort de Jacques Roba qu'en 2021 ceux qui
l'ont côtoyé ont voulu montrer ses
œuvres perpétuer ses savoir-faire
assurer sa postérité le vernis a joué un
rôle protecteur c'est à dire que l'acide
n'a attaqué que là où la pointe a dénudé
le vernis donc maintenant l'acide a
creuser le le cuivre on va retirer le
vernis et on pourra s'apercevoir que le
que le cuivre est creusé désormais ben
là c'est l'ancrage avec une poupée
poupée artisanale qui a été faite par
Jacques avec un manche à balai du cuir
qui permet de
rentrer l'encre dans les creux avant de
partir il m'avait laissé entendre qu'il
souhaitait que cet atelier garde cet
esprit et que on puisse continuer de
transmettre l'art de la gravure l'amour
de cet art donc je m'y suis à clé avec
l'association atelier de gravure Jacoba
qui animent la place annonce cet atelier
permet de le garder vivant
[Musique]
un atelier vivant ouvert aux artistes
chevronnés comme débutants pour Elisa le
Veillard cette première estampe est un
raté mais la jeune femme aura bien
d'autres tentative pour perfectionner
son tour de main on a trop essuyé donc
c'est la prochaine qui va être bien